Do you sometimes just want to smash
people's face in with good honest beat
sticks? Not having to worry about the
stack priorities or your friend's
feelings. Well, ever since the early
days, I remember being pummeled by my
friend Eric Stonebrow beatdown deck and
that's how grow spreads. It seems like
get smashed enough and eventually you'll
join the smashing. Enter Helena and
Alina. They are some of the strongest
and most underrated G commanders I've
ever built. But who am I and why are you
listening to me? Well, hello. This is
Jyn from Next Level Commander Magic
Commander EDH. That's all I do. So, if
you enjoy this content, please like and
subscribe for more. So, looking at
Helena and Alina. I'll just call them by
their couple name. Helina. Yeah, Helena
will do. Helina's ability seems fairly
basic, but it's not. And you will see
why in a second. I'm guessing most
people looking for a similar profile
gravitated towards Xenos, which is
understandable. I mean, Xenos is sweet,
but by comparison, Helena, what's that?
Oh, Helina offers a more consistent and
sustainable game plan. What's the plan,
you ask? Well, we're not playing the
typical Goro beaters. No, none of them.
We're going for synergy with our
commander. And it turns out cards that
synergize with our commander also do
with each other. Now, I know this is
slightly more thinking than what the
average Ghoul player is used to doing,
but just bear with me for a second. It's
worth it. We're making a feedback loop.
Yes. You know how when you place a mic
too close to the speakers and the sound
feeds into itself and it quickly becomes
unbearable?
No. Okay. I hope your volume is kept low
because I'm playing that sound for you
in 3 2 1. Just kidding. I'm not here to
torment you. We save that for your play
group. Their ears will definitely be
ringing once Helina is done with them.
So, how does it work? We're playing only
threats that can pump Helina before
combat, which in turn pump themselves.
Take my favorite one for example,
Wolfear Silver Heart. Quick maths. We
drop our commander and then this the
turn after. How much are we attacking
for?
20. Six from the commander and 14 from
wolffir. Seems decent. That's what the
deck is about. Let's start with the
biggest pumps. Verdor's gearhulk isn't
quite as good as the wolf, but there's
more flexibility with how you distribute
the counters and they stick around even
if the gearhulk gets removed. Oric of
the crayon horde also pumps for four,
but once in a while we can politic
someone into allowing us to transform to
deal with a threat. Bristly Bill for
just two mana can do a ton of work with
counters and the activated ability can
finish games all on its own. Master
Seymour is like another copy of our
commander. Ordery Tumblew. Holy crap.
This name may not seem that impactful at
first, but even then dropping this after
our commander, you're attacking for
eight with haste. And if you get the
chance to saddle it once or twice, it
will go out of hand fast. As we go
deeper into the game, the doublers begin
to shine. Zenagos definitely makes the
cut. He also kind of does an impression
of our commander. Besides that, the
doubling from God Eternal Ronas and
Zopentrol Hunger Dominus can straight up
finish games with a decent board.
Sigardian Zelot is one of the best cards
in this deck because it pumps the board
based on its own power. And let's just
say it's never going to be three. And
we've got a few more like this. They
don't just boost the commander, but also
the entire board. The new orid is sweet.
And Bortas Gleas may have been victim to
power creep, but the Anthem is still
relevant enough. And evasive creatures
is always nice. Ava Brock caretaker is
quite expensive for what it does
considering how hard it is to flip a
werewolf in Idiage, but I want to
believe. Now on to cards that don't pump
so much but provide utility. Enduring
courage and ogre battle driver because
haste is just so important in a beatdown
deck in case our commander gets removed.
Arazzi linebreaker and reckless
stormseker are mini versions of that.
Bloods Sworn Steward and Guardian
Augment provide pump and utility for
Helina to thrive. While Darren
Throwseeker pumps for too early game and
can quickly grow into a threat your
opponents will have to play around. And
in the late late game, if you have
something massive, this can just be a
fling in a pinch to wrap things up. The
Follower of Vigor is just such a pushed
card with cost reduction, pump, and a
massive body for just five mana. And we
toss in the Doomscar warrior and
emergent woodworm for some value as we
send in the beats. And this wraps up the
you big me big section. We also do have
a few creatures that benefit from
growing insights. Herm Blade Elite is a
bit awkward here as a three cost mana
dork, but it's just so nice with its set
of abilities being able to be in for
damage and tap for a ton of mana. Lifeb
Blood Hydra is expensive to cast, but as
it grows with our I don't know 25 pump
effects, we can cash it in for a payday
later on. Dread Horde Archanist is a bit
narrow, but when it fires, it's so much
value. Early game we're getting double
ramping growth and late game it becomes
double Shandra ignitions and double
liver streams blessings. Spike shot
elder is an old favorite of mine from
Meridan and it's absolutely at home
here. Three mana for five damage
repeated is already pretty excellent and
is often more than that much more. And
lastly, Pathbreaker Evex. It does
everything except pumping our commander.
But every time I drop this with haste,
the game ends soon after. So it's
probably a good card. And yep, that's
the core of our game plan. What's nice
about this deck compared to something
like Zenena Ghost is that every creature
here is a threat that sticks around,
especially if the commander gets to do
its thing. But even if Helina gets
removed, our creatures will still feed
into each other and eventually overwhelm
our opponents. Now, time for some
utility. Let's start with ramp. Our
commander is four mana, so we're
prioritizing two drops. The Lens search
effects are good, but these creatures
are even better because we have
something to pump right away when we
drop Helina on turn three. The great
hench doesn't help at all in the early
game, but it's just too much value to
throw away. And while we're being
greedy, traverse the outlands. Not the
most reliable effect, but if we get to
fire this off, we are set for life. For
card draw, we have Silven Library to
cover our bases. While Greater Good,
Hunter's Insight, Return of the Wild
Speaker, and Liveream's Blessing will
send us straight to Value Town.
Inspiring Call is a protection spell,
but in a pinch, we can absolutely fire
it off for three to four cards. We're
fairly light on removals and for board
wipes, we're prioritizing the damage
based ones cuz I mean our board grows
big enough that often times these are
one-sided. A little bit of protection
because our commander is a removal
magnet as soon as our opponents figure
out what we're doing. Rhythm of the wild
is pump or haste depending on what's
needed. And Garuk's uprising will help
our creatures reach our opponent's faces
rather than getting distracted by some
depressed robots. And let's round things
up with our Rancor for some reusable
pump and a worldly tutor cuz why not?
For utility lands, we're prioritizing
haste enablers. Some of the MDFCs are
sweet, too, but don't get too greedy
with them. Play them as lands unless
it's beyond obvious that you don't need
another one. And here you have it. The
deck is fairly explosive, but not with
the best resilience, as our cards can
get a bit expensive, and it may be
difficult to keep up in the late game if
we don't ramp well early. The deck is
fairly easy to play. The toughest
decision is probably something like do I
pump oral with our commander first or
vice versa. The budget is mid to high
and this is a bracket three deck. So
yeah, this is Jin with Next Level
Commander and if you enjoy smashing as
much as I do, please like and subscribe.
What is your smashiest deck? And let me
know in the comments.